about 10 miles from that minnesota
courthouse another story is making
headlines today
brooklyn center minnesota police held a
press conference this morning
to discuss the death of duante wright
wright was shot and killed by officers
yesterday during a traffic stop
there's this video of it this morning
the department released this body camera
footage
it shows wright trying to get away there
from police but then
the police chief says one of the
officers involved opened fire
that officer allegedly thought it was a
taser but it was a gun
the officer had the intention to deploy
their taser but instead shot mr right
with a single bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in the tragic death
of mr right the department will review
the footage and decide if that officer
will be punished
she has been placed on administrative
leave though during the investigation